what is human nature well I think human
nature above and beyond anything else is
a is a perception and that perception to
echo a little bit of what I've just said
will other position itself in synergy
with its surrounding or a whole position
itself in a predatory or in an
antagonistic position meaning by that
that we will use other resources to our
own to for the promotion of our own
needs and you know human nature is a
philosophy ultimately philosophy that
defines how we fit in the universe how
do we fit within the natural order and
how would we fit within the spiritual
order if the question is what is my
personal philosophy on human nature then
I would have to say that that human
nature is a work in progress that has a
tremendous potential but also has a lot
of shortcomings the pitfalls of which
have tremendous consequences on our own
ability to survive
you